[Music]
so good to see you in this movie because
it's such a departure from how we see
you on Modern Family yeah if we get
intentional it definitely doing
something different is definitely
intentional for me because I want to
broaden my horizons and I want to do
more movies and I would like to do
different things obviously because I've
been doing this show for next year will
be a ten years so I definitely want to
do new things and and I think this movie
is an amazing gateway and I'm super
proud of it and working with bird is
incredible so very lucky because Clinton
Jack and Bobby general one you are the
only one stupid enough to show up
there's this quote in this movie and I
feel like it's an overall theme about
how Hollywood can build you up but it
can tear you down just as quickly how
have you felt that Hollywood has treated
you I think it's definitely been
interesting
I think Hollywood kind of puts up a
front all the time where it's like you
know we love everybody and and we're you
know this person is so great and and
they look so great and they're doing so
great and then it's like in an instant
somebody can make a mistake or just do
something in their life that really is
not anything crazy or or just really
just have like life experiences and like
moments and I feel like anything in
Hollywood can like automatically have
tons of people just attacking you for no
reason or it's like one day you did
something great and then the next day
you're like plastered I said that was
into other things it's it's a really
difficult industry I mean we're blessed
to be in it I'm gonna be able to make
content that we love and that other
people love but it's also an industry
that it is true it builds you up and it
can tear you down just as fast but
you've navigated it so well you're only
20 years old it's impressive but I also
I think the key to doing that is trying
to stay out of the spotlight as much as
possible unless you know you're doing
something that you want people to see or
it's kind of like having every little
aspect of your life in the public eye
it's really hard if it gives more room
for criticism and and it's like I just
want to live and so I think I try and
stay out of it as much as possible
unless I need to be in it I feel like
you actually have taken a step back from
even like stepping out and the paparazzi
pictures is that it's not been
intentional yeah I I don't really go
anywhere to be seen or anything like
that like I'll go to a red carpet if I'm
in it or if I'm supporting my boyfriend
or my friends or people like that and
but otherwise I usually just stay home
paparazzi is kind of really getting on
my last nerve cuz it's like I really
don't do anything exciting and they
really seem to think that at one time in
my life they're gonna get something
really juicy and like mainly what Levi
and I do on most nights is like we watch
TV go the grocery store go to the gym go
to the pet store and go back home
so yeah you're a normal couple yeah he
actually said last night we were with
him at his movie premiere and he said
you guys are adopting animals like crazy
are gonna have a farms yeah adopted him
an animal a year and have a bunny now
and we might be getting another bunny so
it really just seems like we keep adding
to the furry family which keeps us home
even more but we love it that's like if
it's really like it's what we like to do
we like spend time together spend time
with the things we love and and just
hang out and be normal because that's
what life is about this what are these
peanut butter and cheese tattoos that he
told us about like what is a significant
we really don't know where it came from
but we just like one day we're like oh
we're peanut butter and cheese we like a
really kind of gross
snip sandwich that's awesome and that
people should definitely try yeah and
put on the ring finger yeah yeah we just
thought we loved it we thought it was a
funny thing that was kind of unique it's
like you know a lot of people get things
that are you know it's like I don't want
to get something that anybody had ever
thought of before and it probably people
have peanut butter and cheese tattoos
somewhere I doubt it
maybe peanut butter jelly them so peanut
butter and cheese for us as far as about
what's the significance of having it on
this finger does it mean anything am i
reading into it too much it means
something but it means something that in
a few years would be great okay and then
UCLA your collegiate experience you
started in September what have you enjoy
the most about it so far
I do love UCLA but at the moment I am
taking a break from it so I can continue
to pursue my career and and also try and
have a little bit more of a life because
I've been so busy so that's really it's
really at the moment but I think
education is really important I love
being there I love learning I'll
continue to keep learning and and just
wanted to take a break to focus on
myself and square some things with
myself down um let's talk about the next
chapter just very briefly because
obviously you took a break from UCLA but
you are doing movies now Modern Family
is ending what do you see for yourself
what do you hope for yourself well I
mean I would I would hope to do more
movies but really anything that comes my
way that speaks to me or feels right or
it's something a new character I haven't
done before I'm I'm pretty open you know
I like doing different things I like
trying things so for me it's it's really
whatever happens yeah and lastly you
tweeted last year about your anxiety and
I've never heard you speak about anxiety
before is that something that you have
struggled with and I think everybody
does to a certain extent I think
everybody struggles with mental illness
in some form I think there's a huge
stigma around it and I don't believe in
that at all I think it's absolutely
ridiculous and also there's a huge
misconception that people can only
getting that like people who have money
or fame or do this like people don't
struggle with anxiety and and it's it's
kind of pointless and I think everybody
should be able to share their story and
and have a voice to do it and go through
it together and and make it kind of like
a community because I feel like people
need to understand that everybody has
anxiety or has depression or has
something and it's not a person being
broken or having a both it's it's just
like life and it's being human yeah how
have you been able to handle it like
what's the key for you
um it mainly it's you know you try and
center yourself in reality and then you
talk to people that love you and you
there are tons of different methods for
people you know I go to therapy and I
think therapy is great some people don't
believe in therapy some people think
therapy is like only for broken people
it's not therapies for everyone it's
awesome I you know like I said staying
out of the limelight when I don't have
to be is also nice it really like put
you back in your life and lastly working
with Burt Reynolds everything you
thought it would be and more he's an
awesome guy I mean he's he's a legend in
general and and he's just a really
incredible person and I'm very honored
to have worked with him and to know him
and he's a lovely human being an
incredible actor and and I'm very lucky
[Music]
[Applause]